let's talk about the job market real
quick behind rise in unemployment job
market is really strong this is a Wall
Street Journal story uh and there's two
stories back to back I'll read both of
them here for you on what's going on
with the job market so
uh unemployment rate increased to 3.7
from 3.4 percent in May but the numbers
of job search indicating a strong job
market the the household survey which
determines the unemployment rate showed
a decline in employment but when
adjusted to payroll definition household
employment actually increased by 394 000
wages remain firm with a slight
deceleration in overall wages in May but
wages for non-management employees Rose
by half a percent over the past three
months both overall wages and
non-management earnings continue to grow
at rate that showed no sign of
deceleration which may unsettle the
Federal Reserve Health Care government
and you know what that means right that
means interest rates about to increase
Healthcare government professional
sectors added the most jobs while the
information sector experienced a decline
possibly due to a rider strike and then
this leads to the next story U.S job
openings Rose in April reversing
three-month decline
your job openings Rose in April
reversing three-month job decline
indicating strong employer demand
despite a gradual uh slowing economy the
labor department uh reported a
seasonally adjusted 10.1 million jobs in
April up from 9.7 million jobs layoffs
decreased to 1.6 million in April
further highlighting a solid labor
market while job openings have declined
from the record high of 12 million in
May in March of 2022
uh they still outnumbered the 5.7
million actively seeking in April
various sectors experience changes in
job openings would increase as seen in
retail warehouses Healthcare and
transportation while declines were
observed in factories real estate firms
and state local governments the number
of workers quitting their jobs held
steady indicating confidence in finding
new employment opportunities Tom so
there's a couple things going on here
and uh hey Rob can you find look up this
type Fred initial
claims initial job claims Fred and
you'll get this blue chart right here
Fred not the fed Fred interesting that's
a new one
there you go so what's going on here is
two things that we need to there we go
St Louis that's it let's take a look at
this watch for the blue line there's
another
another chart in there but what we've
got here is initial job claims have
suddenly spiked I don't mean a little
Tom can I see that go ahead keep saying
it um and just look at the blue line on
the far left yeah and what happens to
that blue line um and that came out that
came out yesterday so the initial job
claims come out what is an initial job
claim that's someone after six weeks
says I've been unable to find work I
need unemployment assistance and to get
it from the state so you go to the
unemployment office so those claims are
way up the other one is Rob let's just
go to show the tweet that I had from
Danielle
and what was very interesting going on
here take a look at this there is
the labor department made a birth death
adjustment whoops or we we got this
wrong on birth death they changed it and
look what they did to their own chart
Pat whack
their chart takes this whack and
Danielle and others came out and said
this is Daniel demartino Booth who's an
expert on fed statistics if you look at
the past 12 months 37 of the jobs were
made by a birth death adjustment in
other words they weren't make so when
they say that job creation was up 37 of
those is a data correction and it is a
pure estimate from our government what's
not an estimate from our government is
that jobless claims just spiked last
week as people are looking for real
checks so if there's real jobs out there
and the job growth is up then why are so
many people looking for checks this is
the conflict that's in our Labor
Statistics we've had people recently
that were here on pbd podcast who said
how is it that the government 14 months
in a row kept beating the labor stats
remember that Pat it's because they make
an announcement they go in the
background they quietly adjust it and
then next week they say oh we beat our
estimate so there's a lot of BS going on
and all I I got to say is look at the
number of people laid off look at what's
going in the housing market look at the
number of initial jobless claims I don't
care about the job creation stats when I
look around my community and I can see
people that are in line for unemployment
checks and I see what's going on
um this is the government specifically
Biden Administration is creating good
news out of statistics and there's a
couple times that they've done some
magic spreadsheet work look at that
Spike Pat that was an adjustment that
they made in birth debts the dirt's
going this way no no sorry it's up here
and and you've got experts on this like
Danielle will come out and say 37 of
those jobs are made by a spreadsheet
thank you for that uh breakdown no I
genuinely that's a little more the value
can I add a little attainment to this
thing this other article here I think is
is very entertaining here let me just
read it real quick it's basically
um it's an article from The Insider it
says no job no problem for some they
call here's a new term fun employment
summer after quitting sounds like a
perfect job fun employment is a term for
embracing joblessness as liberating and
empowering prioritizing personal
Pursuits and self-reflection it's about
enjoying life
rather than rushing into a new job the
pandemic has shifted perspectives on
work and life leading to burnout and
restlessness around 28 of laid off
workers plan to take a break before
their next job recognizing the
opportunity of self-care and exploration
those with savings and Severance are
taking advantage of fun employment
summer
they pursue passions personal growth and
even make career changes realizing that
traditional work may not bring them
fulfillment people want to have that
work-life balance people want to have
that fun
mid-summer you know last year was hot
girl summer yeah then before that I
think it was white boy songs
now it's fun employment summer who needs
money we can get money from the
government baby exactly and let's go
back and if you can you take us back to
your man on the street interview with a
young woman that came from New York with
that government money to have a fun
employment week There's a beginning in
the middle to end of this fun employment
the beginning is you gotta check from
the government for six thousand dollars
what are you gonna do with that money
I'm going on spring break vacation I
said oh they were only giving out 1800
bucks how'd you get six grand or so she
goes I got dependents maybe oh you got
kids I go by the way how much did you
spend on this vacation six thousand
dollars uh how much money you have left
in the account after this trip I have no
money left okay sounds like that fun
employment's gonna be coming to an end
and you're gonna have what is called
unemployment at that point then you're
gonna need to be collecting unemployment
checks and then you need to be back on
the government situation again
unemployment leads to no money after a
while she's looking for someone to take
her to dinner and you were a cute guy
with a microphone and Vinnie exactly
that's what happens when these girls
collect them fun employment checks they
all they want they want some dude out
there to start funding their lifestyle
gentlemen be very careful hey if you
enjoyed this short hope you want to
watch the whole thing click over here
but if you want to make 2023 the
beginning of the greatest years of your
life I host a conference once year it's
called the Volcom difference where three
thousand CEOs executive entrepreneurs
from around the world come together to
strategize for three and a half days
this year it's going to be at Miami
Diplomat Resort and the speakers this
year is going to be Tom Brady he'll be
there I'll be interviewing him Mike
Tyson will get Dara the guy that ran 11
Madison in New York if you run a
business if you're a CEO entrepreneur
and executive this is not an event you
want to miss out on get yourself your
spouse your business partner your
running mates registered and I look
forward to seeing you there click on the
link here or see the link in the
description and I hope to spend three
and a half days with you in Miami in
August and September take care everybody
thank you